hey guys Pete here this will be my
better call Saul season 5 episode 2
recap and review 50% off did something
I'm really excited about it brought
jimmy back into nachos orbit at the end
which means we may see the two different
parts of this story finally mesh back
together in preparation for the end game
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
episode 2 a better call Saul season 5
this video will spoil it for you hit the
subscribe button tap the bell for
notifications and then go watch the
episode come back here after because I
will be making videos throughout this
season season 5 second episode is titled
50% off that's in reference to the deal
that Jimmy discussed with Kim in episode
1
she thought it might come off as
encouraging people to commit crimes if
he made this offer he didn't think that
was possible since of course these guys
are criminals and they're already out
there doing that anyway but he did
decide not to use the offer only to
change his mind in the heat of the
moment later when he was around the
customers the episode written by Allison
Tatlock and directed by Norberto Barba
follows two characters who were indeed
inspired to go on a spree by Saul's
offer because dude that's like almost
half these two Badger and skinny P desk
flunkies go on a meth filled tear that
makes for an enjoyable opening montage I
mentioned in my episode 1 video that
nacho is the most interesting part of
the cartel side of things for me and
after the opening credits we get a
reminder of just how messed up his
situation is and this does turn out to
be a pretty nacho heavy episode Tyrus
and Viktor snatched him out of bed and
you got a feel for nacho here since he
has no idea why this is happening
considering he did exactly what Gus
instructed him to do if being forced out
of bed in the middle of the night isn't
bad enough things quickly escalate to
the worst-case nightmare scenario that
he finds himself in they take him to a
place where his father is hanging out
and Viktor goes inside with the gun
while nacho has to sit there and watch
Gus gets inside the car and tells nacho
that he needs to know what Lala
Salamanca is up to where he is going
what he's thinking what he is planning I
need to know what he's going to do
before he does it
nacho has been trying to keep tabs but
Lala has been primarily focused on
burner
mic Gus uses the threat to Papa to get
nacho to try harder and this is classic
Breaking Bad Gus fring this is the guy
who slit Victor's throat in front of
Walt and Jesse and by the end of this
interaction nacho knows his neck is on
the line because Lala doesn't believe
Gus's cover story about the construction
project he goes to visit his tio Hector
at Casa tranquila while he's talking
about Don Eladio and Juan bolsa not
caring about Gus because of the money
that he makes Hector gets his bell
ringing finger and high gear Lalo gets
the message and realizes the only way to
get at Gus is to mess with his money and
get him in trouble with the cartel nacho
and Lalo come together at a poker game
where we see how Domingo who we know as
crazy ate from Breaking Bad got his name
Lalo takes the opportunity to make a big
bluff holding seven deuce on the river
to get Domingo to fold the best hand
before he drags the pot he flips over
his opponents hand to see that he had a
set of eights
as he collects the chips he says Oh Joe
loco this guy and the name Crazy eight
is born while the Salamanca crew was
playing poker are 50% off numbskulls had
arrived at the stash house looking to
score ten bags apparently their spree is
still ongoing and based on the big buy
it appears that things are going their
way the bags got stuck in the drainpipe
on the way down and so now Crazy eight
has to come to the spot and try to
figure out what's going on he gets up on
the ladder to try to fix the pipe right
at the same time the cops roll up on the
location everyone scatters and they all
get away but he's left on the ladder and
has to talk to the police when he gets
down as he's doing that he taps on the
pipe the bags drop out right in front of
them and he gets arrested Lalo and nacho
arrived on the scene to check on the
stash house and this provides an
opportunity for nacho to make a daring
attempt to earn Lala's trust he sneaks
into the house because there's still a
lot of drugs there and he recovers the
stash just before the police bust down
the door well it's a little crazy this
should help move things in the right
direction for him one of the things that
makes Lalo a good character is that he's
no dummy but I really doubt that this
will strike him as a desperate move by
someone who is working against his
interests that seems to be confirmed
later when back at the restaurant Lalo
makes food and has not
to eat with him so that they can discuss
krazy-8 the most exciting thing about
all of this is that Domingo aka krazy-8
is now in custody considering we know he
was a confidential informant for the DEA
and specifically for one Hank Schrader
and the Breaking Bad timeline and that
we also know that Hank will be making
appearance in the next couple of
episodes that table is now set after
watching him fold the best hand in the
poker game Lalo has to be wondering if
he'll be able to hold up under the
pressure of being questioned when not to
ask if he wants him to take care of it
Lalo says no I got something much better
for him this is probably tied to what we
see at the end of the episode so we'll
pick back up with it when we get there
and Jimmy and Kim land things aren't
going very smoothly it feels like Kim is
angry about what happened with her pro
bono client on top of not being fully on
board with a decision to practice law as
Saul Goodman Jimmy's plans to bring
customers in is working but he can also
sense the unease that Kim is having he
tries to improve the situation by taking
her to an open house to give her some
hope about a future they could have
together this seems to work on some
level as she turns the shower on with
him inside getting him all wet that's a
reminder that they do have strong
feelings for each other and enjoy each
other despite the current situation on
the way out she says maybe someday and
it's comforting to see that there are
feelings that a future could be built on
still there earlier at home Kim asked
Jimmy how he was gonna deal with so many
new clients and we see him take things
head-on at the courthouse we see him
wheeling and dealing again with bill
from the DA's office but he's got bigger
things on his mind with a DA Susan
Erickson who you'll remember from Hills
case last season while he's waiting for
her he runs into Howard Hamlin who makes
his first season five appearance and I
must say he's looking a whole lot better
than the last time we saw him Howard
congratulate Jimmy on being reinstated
and mentions that Hamlin Hamlin McGill
is set to have one of their best years
ever he seems genuinely happy to see
Jimmy even if he doesn't really like the
new choice of name and the idea that
things are going so well at HHM is
definitely surprising the big surprise
here though is that Howard asked Jimmy
to have lunch with him we don't get to
find out what it's all about though
because Susanne eggs
the courtroom we learned that she is
assigned to 16 of Jimmy's cases and he
wants to work out some deals to get them
settled quickly
Suzanne see straight through him and
calls him out on wanting quick turnover
so that he can make more money her
instincts he are good and she's not
willing to work out deals with Jimmy
ahead of their scheduled meeting that's
coming up the next week
Jimmy has Saul has gotten himself into
this situation by offering the
discounted rates and this is where he
actually thrives if she won't respond to
his requests then he will concoct a way
to get an audience this plays out in him
setting up for them to get stuck in an
elevator together he finds a maintenance
man who could use some extra cash and
some legal services and when all is said
and done they have come to an agreement
on 13 out of the 16 cases after being
stuck in the elevator together for 20
minutes after he pulls that off things
are looking pretty good for Saul but
little does he know this day is about to
take a turn before we get into that we
have to address Mike's current situation
we catch up with him
at home he's in bed and he looks broth
the phone is ringing next to empty beer
cans and liquor bottles and he's not
moving very quickly to address that it
turns out Stacey is the one who's
calling and she needs him to come over
and watch Kaylee which he agrees to
without question when he arrives things
start off well he goes into full-on
grandpa mode he helps her with the
multiplication tables using the example
of a football game and touchdowns for
sevens and he makes some progress on the
construction of a tree house when the
discussion turns to Kaylee asking
questions about her dad things go
terribly off the rails
we know that Mike's going through a lot
of stuff he's currently dealing with the
remorse over burner and it appears that
thinking about Maddy and what happened
to him after he joined the police force
to be a cop like Mike is sufficient
enough to send him over the edge he
completely loses his cool with his
granddaughter yelling you either do it
right or you don't do it which leads to
her running away to her room when her
mom returns he leaves without explaining
much other than Kaylee was in her room
and wouldn't eat dinner
we know Mike can be a hard person when
he has to be but this was pretty
perplexing and difficult to watch if
there was any question as to how he's
holding up after the events of season 4
I think this clears it up we close out
the
episode with Jimmy who's enjoying an
ice-cream cone after his elevator
encounter with the ad a he's taking
calls and working his magic as nacho
pulls up which I'm guessing is related
to Lalo's plans that he mentioned
earlier it's actually been a long time
since these two have been together way
back in season one with the kettlemans
and the way things were left at that
time Jimmy has no choice but to go along
with nacho here as he does owe him he
gets in the car
unfortunately the ice cream cone can't
come along which is a big loss and they
drive off together and this is sort of
like everything finally coming full
circle
better call Saul is undoubtedly one of
the best television shows that's on
currently but if there's one criticism
that comes up about the show over and
over it's about how the two stories the
one with Jimmy and the one with Mike
kind of exists beside each other rather
than being intertwined that's what makes
this ending so exciting the fact that
Jimmy is going to have to work for nacho
which of course works for Lalo really
moves us firmly into the endgame
remember when we first met Jimmy these
are the two people's names he mentioned
whenever he was being questioned by Walt
and Jesse the show has taken some time
to get there actually more time than
what they had originally planned based
on the fact that Jimmy and choc and that
whole storyline was so good but now we
have finally arrived it's funny on top
of that because Jimmy's deal his 50% off
deal is what set off the spree that
landed those two kids outside of the
stash house that set up Domingo aka
crazy eight getting busted and now he's
bringing jimmy nacho Lalo Gus Mike and
everybody inevitably back together it's
a pretty exciting ending and a pretty
good episode overall we're starting to
see Jimmy hit his stride as being Saul
Goodman we're starting to see the divide
between him and Kim widen a little bit
and we're primed to cross over with
Breaking Bad characters Hank and Gomi
which is going to provide a lot of
fanservice at the same time I like the
one-two punch they delivered here with
these first two episodes releasing them
back-to-back
everything seems to be caught up to
speed
and the table seems to be set I'm
curious to see what Lalo is up to heck
you're telling him to go after the money
is interesting and of course how he's
going to choose to deal with Domingo now
that he's been taken into custody I hope
we don't spend too much time with Mike
being in this dark place that he's at in
this episode with so much other stuff
going on it seems a little bit
superfluous and that we know where
Mike's story goes but I'm not exactly
worried about it because I have a lot of
trust in the writers of this television
show because they are some of the best
in the game let me know in the comments
what you guys thought about this episode
how do you feel about season 5 so far
it's kind of strange because it's hard
to decide whether it's Jimmy or Saul a
lot of times when I'm writing these
things out now he's still somewhere in
between and depending on if he's with
Kim or if he's at work we see a little
bit of both still that brings up the
idea that I've heard Bob Odenkirk say in
a couple of different interviews before
the season started about how Saul is a
persona what we see in Breaking Bad is a
persona I'll be interested to see how
his evolution continues please like this
video if you enjoyed it please leave
comments or questions and let me know
where you think things are going please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already I'll be covering this season and
the final one all the way through I may
come up with a couple bonus videos in
between but I'll definitely be doing
weekly recaps at the bare minimum thanks
for watching I'll talk to you soon